aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous donner un
objectif inhabituelle à de bâton on a
tendance à penser qu'on va débattre en
gagner le débat on a tendance à penser
qu'on débat pour mieux réfléchir semaine
aussi tendance à penser qu'on débat pour
convaincre l'autre et bien aujourd'hui
je vais suggérer qu'il existe un autre
objectif qui est tout aussi intéressant
qui est peut-être pas de l'objectif le
plus important de deux bâtons mieux les
canaux via geek tout de même très
intéressant à mettre davantage en avant
à savoir débattre pour s'entraîner à
mieux débattre votre maudit chose qui
est assez intéressant d'imaginer que des
bâtons mieux et est un jeu et qu'on
cherche à gagner à ce jeu en ayant la
discussion la plus des bâtons de mieux
que possible et par discussion très des
bâtons mieux j'entends la capacité à
soulever des réflexions et des
discussions importantes la capacité à
prioriser les sujets intéressants et
importants de débats et la crêpe la cité
être bienveillant
même lorsqu à priori c'est très
difficile d'être bienveillant parce
qu'on aborde des sujets qui sont qui ont
tendance à nous crisper plutôt qu'à
soulever notre bienveillance du coup
faire de cet objectif d'avoir ce genre
de discussion vraiment d'habitude
difficile à voir et de trouver du
plaisir dans ce genre de discussions on
peut en fait en faire un objectif plutôt
que de se faire de cela l'instrument
pour essayer d'en arriver à avoir des
bonnes discussions on peut se dire
aujourd'hui mon objectif dans ce débat
c'est d'avoir un bon débat et je
constate très très motivant fait très
stimulant et on apprend beaucoup parce
qu'à chaque fois que j'essayais de me
donner ça comme objectif dans un débat
bah ça m'a fait un petit peu progressé
typiquement essayer de se donner pour
objectif de réussir à parler d'un sujet
qui d'habitude nous crie ce phénomène
ont énormément mais avec l'objectif de
ne pas se crisper
lorsque l'on débat de la chose et ça
c'est vrai nous force est typiquement a
donné beaucoup plus d'importance avec
calmer le jeu régulièrement à relâcher
l'attention si possible et globalement
du couac simplement mieux débattre et
bien sûr on peut largement sans faire un
objectif individuel c'est dire que voilà
dans ce prochain débat je vais essayer
de faire de mon mieux pour vraiment
mieux débattre et de faire ça plus un
objectif encore que l'objet même du
débat
mais si on peut également y voir un
objectif collectif c'est à dire qu'au
début du débat on peut essayer de se
donner l'objectif de faire en sorte que
ce débat se passe aussi bien que
possible
ça peut paraître assez étrange est un
peu illusoire de prime abord de se
donner ce genre d'objectif mais en fait
c'est quelque chose que j'ai lu
l'occasion de faire à plusieurs reprises
notamment dans des réunions de
l'altruisme efficace nous parfois on a
cet exercice qu'on appelle l'exercice du
double neuf ans et pour tester une
stratégie en particulier de débats dans
des débats difficiles mais de façon plus
intéressante plus générale ce qui est
intéressant dans ce genre de débat c'est
qu'on va typiquement se fixer un
objectif qui est bien débattre et
finalement le débat sera presque
secondaire par rapport à l'objectif de
bien débattre et je dois bien dire qu'à
chaque fois que j'ai testé ce genre de
choses j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement
instructif j'ai beaucoup appris non
seulement sur comment mieux débattre ce
qui est en soi est extrêmement fascinant
mais de façon assez étrange
j'ai également beaucoup appris sur le
sujet même du débat en voulant juste
avoir un bon débat du coup ça se parent
est une stratégie assez assez
intéressante juste pour avoir des bons
débats de chez que de chercher à bien
débattre avoir un débat aussi
bienveillant aussi intéressant si
instructif que possible qu'il fasse
réfléchir tout le monde et je peux vous
garantir que les sujets qu'on a abordé
c'était des sujets à priori assez
controversé parce que dans l'un d'eux il
s'agit de la question des immigrés et de
fermer les frontières à l'immigration et
que dans l'autre cas il s'agissait du
prince du recyclage des déchets et à
chaque fois il y eut des dépositions
vraiment inhabituel qui ont été défendus
mais parce qu'on avait tous les deux à
chaque fois cherché à avant tout bien
débattre en fait ces débats se sont
passées de façon non seulement très dans
la joie et la bonne humeur mais
également de manière extrêmement
instructives et à chaque fois on sait
remercier mutuellement d'avoir eu cette
s'est débarrassé en deux fois quand
cadre est très efficace mais de façon
générale dans beaucoup de débats autour
de la très efficace où il ya un effort
particulier pour avoir un débat aussi
sain aussi productifs que possible
le fait d'avoir cette contrainte en tête
et même quasiment d'en faire un objectif
c'est finalement quelque chose
d'extrêmement instructif du coup je vous
invite à essayer de vous donner comme
objectif d'avoir des débats ou la
bienveillance et ce qui ressortira du
débat j'aimerais conclure en insistant
encore une fois sur l'aspect très jeu
très ludique de cet exercice le fait
d'essayer de trouver du plaisir à
essayer de gagner ensemble finalement à
ce jeu c'est quelque chose qui peut être
extrêmement fun est intéressant et en
particulier je pense que dans le cadre
d'achats que les bâtonnets c'est super
important dans sa maintenance associés à
quelque chose d'extrêmement polarisant
war moulard moralisateur avoir vraiment
quasiment énervant et en fait le fait de
transformer ça en un an je peux changer
complètement la perspective que l'on a
par rapport à des bâtons gueule et de se
rendre compte que oui
certes on va avoir des sujets des
discussions pas toujours ultra facile
sur des sujets sur lesquels ont un petit
peu crispé d'habitude mais en fait en en
transformant ses enjeux on peut faire en
sorte que ces discussions soient non
seulement intéressante mais même
amusante
bon après j'avoue que c'est plus facile
avec certains interlocuteurs qu'avec
d'autres
mais du coup pourquoi ne pas commencer
d'abord avec des débats avec des
personnes avec qui vous pensez que vous
aurez plus de chances de réussir à
aborder des sujets chauds et à être un
petit peu controverse
bref à claques de bâton mieux ce n'est
pas juste cherché à rendre le monde
meilleur
ensemble c'est aussi trouver un maximum
de plaisir et de bonheur en essayant d'y
arriver